and is brought to you today by your
cable or satellite provider
[Music]
good evening thank you all for uh being
here welcome to chevaliers the oldest
independent bookstore in los angeles
we're uh
pleased to be sharing uh our
facility with
the los angeles review of books
one of its board members
one of its board members john weiner is
going to be an interlocutor this evening
i thought i would tell you just a little
bit about who our
guests are tonight john who whom i
whom i know is famous for many things
he's a professor at uh uci riverside
irvine he oh emeritus he owes a he he
owes a book on the 1960s uh to a
publisher i think that's true
um
he is
he's most famous if anybody this evening
needs to know anything about john lennon
or the fbi he is your go-to person he
spent a decade uh litigating to get
access to this information
he is a writer commentator and a man
about town
and a friend of mine
um and he is going to be talking to a
friend of his stephen ross
who is a professor at usc
not ucla
a usc
and i would say of the two of them that
these are uh serious historians who are
not serious about themselves
the work
that
steven will be reading
or talking about tonight and perhaps
reading from
is a really amazing captivating
story that you can't believe it uh
combines the idea of
collusion with foreign powers
the involvement of
entertainment
moguls
doing the right thing
and what was hardest for me to accept
given what i do during the daytime
lawyers who are not concerned about
their billable hour
rates
so if you have an opportunity at the end
of this evening we'll have a wine cheese
signed books and the like i hope you
will buy and read
steve's book and my advice to you would
be to not start it after a dodger world
series game if you intend to uh
sleep at all because the book is
captivating and you'll love it so with
that let me turn it over to
our friends and have them let the games
begin
you forgot one thing about john weiner
one very important that john and his
wife judy introduced me and my wife on a
blind date
more important than any book publication
well thank you for inviting me to do
this conversation it's a completely
fascinating
yarn that you tell here something
historians usually don't get to do
uh i think we better start with the map
this map is the end papers of the book
it's the most striking thing
i've seen in a book in a long time this
is a
map of nazi in fascist los angeles in
the 30s and 40s and
i mean
this is the book in a nutshell there's
an awful lot of swastikas on this map
well the whole point was i as i was
writing this and discovering how many
different
fascist and nazi outlets there were in
the city
uh i started writing down the addresses
and then i convinced my colleague phil
ethington who in addition to being a
superb historian is an unbelievable
photographer and cartographer and so the
two of us worked together
and i thought this is all you need to
know about what it meant to be a jew in
la
from 1933
to 19 let's say 1941
december
working downtown
and this is who you're surrounded by and
you can't see the ledger
the uh swastikas everything in red are
either nazis the swastikas or f
for the fascists
and the main fascist group was the
silver shirts
that were started by william dudley
pelly
and he had been actually a very
successful screenwriter in hollywood who
hated jews and he left the movie
industry despite making a good living
and on
january 30th when hitler became rice
chancellor
he said if a painter
can become the rice chancellor of
germany
and have his brown shirts if mussolini
can have his black shirts then we in
america can have our silver shirts and
tomorrow i am going to launch the silver
shirts of america
and so leon lewis was surrounded by the
silver shirt metropolitan post was the
largest one in the united states
just a few blocks away i don't have up
here was another silver shirt and then
you have these odd fascists the white
guardsmen
the ku klux klan the california
homesteaders the american warriors the
american nationalist party i had easily
six to eight more here but it would have
crowded the map too much and here's what
you need to know
and then we can move on at
charlottesville
they were chanting the jews will not
replace us
downtown l.a this was not in 1933 this
was just a few weeks ago
in downtown from 1933
until pearl harbor virtually every week
if not every two weeks
somebody was chanting death to jews
i have to sigh about that one uh so this
is a map of homegrown local american
nazis
uh they have a lot of sites how many
people are we talking about is this just
a few
nut balls murmuring in their basements
what's the
extent of this
well the the bund are actually the uh
deutsche house here the nazis in la went
through two uh iterations they began
uh gerbos and hitler sent over a german
captain robert pape in march 1933 to
start a nazi organization in los angeles
and in july 26 1933
they held their first open meeting at
the al teidelberg
which is now like an america's best
homes inn or something like this
uh just east of uh just west of downtown
um
and then eventually by 1936 they would
become the german american bund
you had
bun meetings could attract up to
a thousand people but i wouldn't say
they were all committed nazis
my guess is if you're looking at who in
l.a the sort of hardcore nazis you
probably had about three to four hundred
people going to regular meetings and
then the silver shirts collectively you
also had uh they claimed to have
thousands my guess is you probably had
five or six hundred at their peak in la
in la but all you need to know you look
at charlotte's charlottesville you look
at orlando
you look at las vegas
all you need is one crazy person
and when you have three four six eight
thousand
you're gonna have a lot of single crazy
people
now i i had heard that there i i knew
there was a bund in america i knew there
was an america first organization
i didn't really know very much about
hitler himself being interested in los
angeles and sending these emissaries
to los angeles why was hitler interested
in los angeles it's a good question
there were two reasons
uh the first and the most important
is that hitler and his minister
of enlightenment and propaganda
joseph goebbels a phd and it just shows
you where phd can get you
they both loved watching movies and
apparently hitler would like to watch a
movie every night before he went to bed
particularly like walt disney films
because they shared similar political
world view
um they did
that
he also felt
that
had hollywood and great britain not
launched such a successful propaganda
campaign during world war one
against the german government that they
could have gotten a lot more public
support and hitler was determined that
those jews in hollywood
were not going to smear
nazi germany or him self so in june 1933
he sent
george gisling who had been a council in
new york city to los angeles with one
job only and that is to stop hollywood
from making any film that attacked
germany or hitler and of course
hollywood refused to go along with the
proposals his weapon
was article 15 from the german import
law of 1932
which stated that if
any um studio in any country was to make
a film
then in any way denigrated germany
that that studio would have all its
films banned
in germany and if enough studios did
that that whole country would have all
their films banned in germany
and so that was one hammer he used and
within a year
hollywood passed the production code
administration under a lot of pressure
because i know you're going to find this
hard to believe but hollywood was
accused of sexual impropriety back in
the 30s and accused of making horrible
movies and there were people who said
wait a minute you know we we need to
clean up hollywood and one thing the
industry has always done is anytime
anyone has called for federal censorship
they've enacted self-censorship laws so
they created the production code
administration in 1934 that summer and
that also had a clause if you wanted to
be in a first run movie theater which is
where studios made eighty percent of
their profits you had to get a
production coach seal
and they would not give a seal to any
movie that denigrated a foreign nation
or its leader
so gisling had his job made easier by
hollywood as well but here's the thing
the
you had an industry that was run by jews
censored by catholics making films for
protestant children
only in america
it's a wonderful thing so anyway hitler
by stopping hollywood from making any
nazi films anti-nazi films hitler and
gerbils felt it would keep american
public opinion neutral and they wanted
american public opinion neutral until
after they had conquered europe
the second reason they were interested
in la
was less about hollywood than about
smuggling in money spies and secret
orders and propaganda
because uh new york even though it was
closer the new york ports were very
closely guarded because the mayor of new
york uh fiorello laguardia i don't know
how many of you know but fioleta
laguardia was half jewish a court if he
was a reformed jew he would be fully
jewish because his mother was jewish his
father was italian but he also
identified as jewish as well as catholic
and he made sure those ports were
carefully guarded
the nazis referred to new york as jew
york
and they decided that it was too hard to
send things through
and they knew in los angeles both in at
the port of la and down in san pedro
you could get anything through because
nobody was monitoring it you also had a
city where the police the sheriff's
department
had many people who were both
sympathetic if not members of the uh
bund and of the silva shirts
and of the clan especially the clan and
so uh the spies that whose reports i use
for most of the book talk about driving
down to the docks with herman schwinn
who is the head of the bund here and
watching schwinn receive secret sealed
orders from either the captain of the
vessel or from a gestapo officer because
hitler had a gestapo officer on every
german ship that left germany and went
abroad
so hitler and the
nazi
government of germany were very
interested in los angeles because of the
movie industry
your
local la home-grown nazis were also very
interested in the movie industry
right um
which ones are we talking about here
we're talking about the ones who had a
plot to kill jewish stars of hollywood
in studio heads there's so many
of these plots i kind of lose track
myself
uh
yeah the
knots the by the 1930s um and i'm guilty
of this one of the things people one of
the questions i always get asked is how
come we don't know this story
and i said well
my cohort weiner me and our age cohort
we were all concerned with looking at
radicalism in the 30s and 40s
and we were all concerned with exploring
communist and left activity in hollywood
and kind of ignored conservatives
fascists and right wing i plead guilty
well i'm guilty too
uh
and so no one was really looking very
deep into what was going on
and it was only in
you i only discovered this sort of
accidentally by when i was
writing about edward g robinson in the
hollywood anti-nazi league and i'd seen
an online exhibit from cal state
northridge
where it called in our own backyard
which is about fascists and nazis so
went out took a look but they're like
over 200 boxes of these spy reports and
that was too much to look at for what
would have been a page in a book
but when i finished the last book
hollywood left and right i said i'm
going to go back and take a look
and that's when i discovered this story
and one of the things that went on is it
wasn't just the nazis who wanted to kill
jews it was americans
the silver shirts all these other groups
that have all the other names were
overwhelmingly american the nazis had
their own silver shirt post because they
wanted to show their american brethren
that they could be good americans too
but in general the fascists were
operating on their own
and they came up with two plots
one in
1935
35 early 36 which was going to
hang
20 hollywood and political figures from
l.a including busby berkeley
the district attorney baron fitz and
others with the idea that if you hung
these prominent people it would start
pogroms throughout america that you
would have mass killings of jews
well that never happened because the
plotters realized that leon lewis the
hero of my story in the spymaster
had spies inside their organization and
they didn't know who it was
and they knew that if they committed
murder they were going to get arrested
for murder and they weren't going to do
that until they figured out who the spy
was so they postponed it and that
postponement became permanent
but a year later another
fascist came into town leopold
mclaughlin a british fascist who at one
point he was six feet eight
the brother of victor mclaughlin who won
an oscar in 1936 ironically for his role
in the informer
uh and leopold
at one point been the world's jujitsu
champion had taught how to murder
through hand-to-hand combat with both to
both the surte and scotland yard so this
guy may have been nuts but he was a
killer and he had been in the army had
been a captain in the british army and
he had an even
more frightening plot which was he was
going to blow up the homes
of 24
hollywood movie stars and producers from
louis b mayer
down to two christians who he said was
too friendly to the jews charlie chaplin
and james cagney and they were going to
blow up those homes they were to get 24
assassins
working with them they were going to
blow up their homes
they are also preparing they had secured
a boat in
long beach harbor that when any jews
tried to flee by boat they were going to
destroy the boats as they were trying to
leave the harbor as well
and that plot was only foiled because
there were four plotters that was it
and one of the four plotters was leon
lewis's a spy
chuck slocum i think we have to now
switch to the spy story to the spy story
our hero
uh the hero of your book leon lewis and
his his ace spy uh charles slocum who
were the these guys were quite different
yes well
first leon lewis never expected he would
be a spy master he was born
in small town in wisconsin
in the late 1880s
they went to college went to law school
at the university of chicago graduated
1913
and decided he was going to dedicate
himself to tikkun alum healing the world
and so he took a job with this new
organization that had just started
called the anti-defamation league and he
was their founding executive secretary
it was a three-man operation
and one of his responsibilities was also
to monitor hollywood films for
anti-semitism so even as early as 1913
he was working with these
moguls he went off and fought in world
war one
rising from an enlisted private to
captain
came back went back to work for the adl
convinced them that anti-semitism was so
intense in europe they needed to create
an international division and so like
any good person
you suggest something and you get to be
the international head as well as the
national head he stayed with the adl
uh until he moved to la in 1930 31
and assumed his law practice and just
thought he was going to be a lawyer do
his billable hours and lead a
comfortable life
and then hitler rose to power
and he watched this jewish community
split nationally into two groups the
american jewish committee
basically argued you've got to get
aggressive with hitler and they started
an international boycott of all german
products until hitler would stop
persecuting jews and all minorities not
just jews
and they figured this would pressure him
because it would hurt the german economy
the other group the american jewish
congress
uh they argued by led by uh judge
proskauer of proskara rose
they had argued that that would that
hitler would double down if you got in
his face that he was crazy enough if you
tried to pressure him he would go even
more ballistic and therefore they
recommended going through
uh intermediaries particularly religious
leaders in germany well they kept
talking they kept talking and then they
kept talking some more
and after the nazis held their first
open meeting in june or july rather
and at that meeting said look we are
going to save the country from
communists and jews
he said that's enough and he went down
to uh for those of you who drive towards
downtown on the 10
what right before you hit downtown you
see on your right just south of the 10
bob hope patriotic hall
is that familiar to many of you
well that was built by the county
supervisors in 1926 to house veterans
groups
and he was a member leon lewis of the
disabled american veteran so he went
down there
and he got four veterans three
christians one jew and their wives
to agree to join every nazi and fascist
group in la undercover and try to rise
up to positions of power and influence
and to send him daily reports of what he
discovered
and lewis ran that spy operation from
august 1933
to the end of world war ii because even
after pearl harbor when they rounded up
the nazis and fascists
he knew
that l.a was fused with anti-semitism
and in fact his spies told him
anti-semitism went up after pearl harbor
could i interrupt at this point in short
i want to underline the fact that the
spies that he recruited
were not jewish except for one these
were christians who were reporting on
anti-semitism in los angeles that is one
of the fascinating and heartening parts
of your book well what they said is they
were reporting on un-american activities
and the first house on american
activities committee was actually
started by samuel dixteen and it was
started to investigate nazis and
fascists in america and it gotten it got
hijacked
by anti-communists who turned it into a
you know red scare purge in a sense
and the other thing about lewis
is and these
veterans
is
they all knew
that they were working for a jew
and one of the questions my editor asked
me is well didn't didn't they think this
is a jewish operation
and my answer is no
that what they knew is that nazis and
fascists had said they were going to
kill jewish americans
they were going to kill catholic
americans and they were going to kill
black americans
and when he talked to these veterans
they basically said
when you look at those hyphenated things
everything on the left of the hyphen is
an adjective
and the noun is american
and we don't give truck for any group
that is going to kill fellow americans
because of their religion or their race
whether they're jewish american catholic
american black american they are all
americans and we have fought to save our
country we're not allowing a foreign
power to come in and kill other
americans
and that was it really only one jewish
spy he had a few informers who helped
him but they were working
piecemeal but of his major spies only
one was jewish
so there's a lot of shocking things here
the map is shocking the the extent of
nazi
you know presence in los angeles
uh if this murder these murder plots are
shocking to me though the most shocking
thing
uh is
none of these not that hitler was
interested in la the most shocking thing
is the response that leon lewis got when
he took his information to the chief of
police of los angeles
so
within a few weeks
literally just a few weeks of his
operation
his four spies come back and they say
we have uncovered a horrible plot
dietrich gefken
a german emigre who was forced to flee
in germany in the 20s because he had
shot to death
several communists
had gone to san francisco joined the
national guard and had come down to l.a
after he had drawn his own blueprints of
the entire national guard armory with
where all the weapons and ammunition was
held
he was working with so
excuse me he was working with silver
shirts in san diego
who were buying illegally buying weapons
from corrupt marines who got a hold of
some marine like this would be navy
surplus selling it to them they were
drilling in san diego getting ready to
take over the armory there
and then he asked lewis's spies at these
four veterans who were all all officers
and highly placed to get the blueprints
for the armory in la and tell them that
my idea is on the same day
we're going to have
uh a combination of
nazis in all three cities
silver shirts
and nazi vessels that have boarded all
had storm troopers on them they were
going to come up on on onto the
onto the land and join with these people
to take over
the armories in the three cities and
they promised that they would any
officer or soldier who agreed to join
them
would change sides anyone who told them
no would be shot on the spot
would they have done this
well i i can tell you this san diego was
getting ready for it because eventually
leon lewis contacted naval intelligence
but his first stop was to police chief
james tugan davis
head of the
los angeles police
and leon lewis starts telling him about
this
and he says he writes a memo afterwards
two minutes into my talk
davis stopped me and said you don't get
it
hitler is doing the right thing in
germany he's only doing what he has to
do because the jews are totally ruined
his economy
and that the real enemy and the real
danger in america are not the nazis and
fascists here the real danger in l.a
are in boyle heights where all those
communists are and he basically told
lewis as far as he was concerned every
communist was a jew and every jew was a
communist
and he had he wasn't going to do
anything lewis then went to the sheriff
biscaloos
told them the same thing i even
understand the sheriff's department and
the police department at this point had
quite a few nazi supporters and in one
case one of the sheriff's captains
was a nazi working with
mclaughlin leopold mclaughlin
so
they went to the fbi and the fbi said we
can't do anything unless we're ordered
from washington
j hoover did not order
his local bureau
to investigate hermann schwinn the head
of the bunden la
the head of the of the entire western
region
of the german american bund and the
number two nazi in america
hoover did not order him put under
surveillance until the middle of
november 1941.
and we could have a pop quiz if you know
what happened three weeks later
we need to
we need to open this up to questions in
just a minute but uh
one other thing i'd like to ask about a
couple other things i'd like to ask
about
so we've got
the police chief the sheriff the fbi
refused to do anything about this there
are a few good guys uh in your story yes
uh the the goodest of the good guys
would be commander ellis zacharias who
was uh a rare animal which is a jew who
had graduated annapolis
and he became the head of naval
intelligence on the west coast and he
had looked over the information
that leon lewis had been sending him and
was shocked that they weren't paying
closer attention because everything
lewis sent him turned out to be true and
so lewis he was louis's closest ally
in the fight
and then an indirect ally
lewis had an associate spymaster joe
roos
who had begun spying with his uncle
julius cline while they were living in
chicago roose was austrian born berlin
raised his uncle julius cline was
chicago born berlin raised and was
living julius was living in germany
during world war one was captured sent
to a camp escaped and then went back as
a spy for the us army and when he went
to chicago he and his nephew joe russ
started spying on their own on nazis in
chicago in uh late 32 33
so much so that
roos who was working for the hearst
newspapers his editor found out about
this
and said i want you to go talk to our
publisher roy keane
who's the head of the entire illinois
national guard
and imagine this five foot four five
foot five
viennese very shy jew with bottleneck
glasses and a very heavy accent goes in
to talk to the publisher is scared to
death
the publisher says is all this true and
he says yes and he gives him a piece of
paper he says
i want you to go to this hotel
in chicago
you're going to meet with the military
man whatever he tells you to do
you do and now i'm ordering you as the
head of the national guard and don't
worry about your newspaper assignments
so he goes to the bismarck hotel and he
meets with an army colonel he tells the
colonel everything that was going that
he and his uncle had been doing
and the colonel says you guys are
amazing
but you have no training i'm going to
have i'm turning you over to my
some of my elite forces who are going to
train you and counter espionage and so
joe roos has changed
trained in countering espionage well
that colonel did okay for himself his
name was george c marshall
he then became head of the army he
became head of army intelligence and
eventually secretary of state marshall
and from 1933 on from that moment
uh roose and uh his uncle julius klein
kept sending uh george c marshall
reports on nazi activities and if you go
to the george c marshall papers i know
you could all go there after you get out
of here
uh i found those reports there he was
sending them through the end of the war
and
ruse's uncle julius cline rose up to be
the highest ranking jew in the army as a
brigadier general by the end of the war
my last question before we open it up i
i know that this uh this story's got a
personal angle to it for you
yeah well my parents were both survivors
my father had been in the warsaw ghetto
and when that was
uh
shut down by the nazis he was shipped
off to dachau
my mother had been in the lodge ghetto
and she was when that was destroyed she
was sent to auschwitz
and after three days in auschwitz they
asked for volunteers to go to a work
camp and tell them that whoever whatever
women whichever women volunteer we could
give you a shower and then send you to
the work camp and my mother said we knew
what the shower meant everyone knew what
that was and she said after three days
in auschwitz
if this is what life was going to be
like i wanted to shower
and so she volunteered and she said
the fact that all these women we are
standing naked hugging one another with
our last breath
the fact that none of us had a heart
attack when water came out of the shower
heads and not gas
is amazing and she was sent by auschwitz
to bergen-belsen and then dissolves
vedal to a munitions camp for the rest
of the war
and my parents met in munich after the
war and
came to america
and the opening of my prologue is about
listening to my mother every single
night throughout my childhood
tell me her nightmares about the gestapo
coming to our home and either taking her
away or my sister and i
so we are very my sister and i are very
typical second
generation children suffering
from the
neuroses of second generation children
as well as the energy
of to achieve that second generation
children especially if your second
generation firstborn
boy
well steve thank you for your energy and
thank you for this book and thank you
for talking about it tonight
it's an incredible story and you've done
a fantastic job of archival research as
well as storytelling uh we have a few
minutes for questions here you all know
the rules about questions do you have a
question let me just say that the
question just let people know that our
goal here is to have the questions be
actually questions rather than
statements thank you very much we'd like
you to speak into the microphone
for our audience and here's a microphone
we have someone in the front who'd like
to go first
we have another microphone
well we have here's our microphone this
is our microphone
yeah this is being taped for c-span so
if you have for book tv if you have a
question
can if you can come up
to the mic
so i have a question but let me begin
contrary to what john has just
instructed
by um by thanking you for doing this i
thought this was wonderful and i i'm
always
made better by the opportunity to listen
to brilliant people telling interesting
stories about important things so thank
you very much
speaking of stories
your book provides
some of the few positive anecdotes
about the movie moguls
like louis b mayer and jack warner i
wonder if you could talk a little bit
about perhaps their
mixed motives in assisting
leon lewis and
talk about how they got started and
where it went and the second part of my
over long question here is
could you also discuss the importance of
leadership
and whether you think this
could have this this
thwarting of the nazis in los angeles
could have occurred without
a man to take the lead would it have
been a spontaneous kind of
operation if there wasn't a great leader
all right to answer the second question
first no it would not take
you need leadership the one thing i'm
convinced now is you absolutely need
leadership no matter how democratic your
organization is
there needs uh to be somebody when
occupy wall street one of the reasons it
fell apart it wanted to be as democratic
as you could be with no leaders but
there has to be leaders i'm sorry leon
lewis was a reluctant leader he never
wanted to be one
but he was one and he did it for all
those years now bert i forgot the first
part of the question oh the moguls
yes well
part of this is uh there's a book that
came out a very bad book that came out
in um
2013 called the collaboration
hollywood's pack with hitler
that my friends and i agree that if this
man had been one of our phd students he
never would have published that
dissertation
it is a teleological dissertation he
he basically writes it from the point of
view of knowing the holocaust happened
why didn't the moguls do more to stop it
that's his take and that they
collaborate because they stayed in
business
with the nazis they were collaborators
well it's an a historical point of view
and he also got the moguls totally wrong
which is the moguls
first of all hollywood is first and
foremost in the money-making business
not the consciousness raising business
when the book came out i got interviewed
by the new york times and the first
question they asked me which really
pissed me off
was
don't you think the moguls were guilty
of collaboration and i said why don't
you start by asking me i'll deal with
that but first ask me was ibm guilty of
collaboration were dow chemicals guilty
of collaboration was ford guilty of
collaboration was u.s steeled guilty of
collaboration all these people
were supplying the german war machine
with machinery
the jews were making movies
i i think it's a kind of anti-semitic
attack
to start with the jews as collaborators
they were doing business
but here's the thing they were also
representing corporations
for good and for bad
but they didn't like it
leon lewis as i mentioned never expected
to be
a spymaster he did not start this as a
vigilante
organization and it's one of the things
i feel a little uncomfortable about when
people ask me now well what what should
we do you know should we you know start
aspiring like leon lewis i think it's a
very dangerous
thing to recommend in part because three
of his spies died under very suspicious
circumstances and i'm convinced at least
two of the three were killed
once leon lewis realized there was no
help from any government agency
you could get somebody to listen to you
later on but that took years he had to
do it on his own and he had basically
given up his law practice and was out of
money he was running this out of his own
pocket
and finally he turned to three friends
mendel silverberg who was the most
powerful entertainment attorney in the
united states
and also one of the five most powerful
people in the republican party he's one
of the five guys who went behind the
closed doors with the smoke fill room to
decide who was going to be the gop
republican presidential candidate
the second person he went to was his
good friend irving thalberg the number
two man at mgm and the third person was
rabbi magnan head of the most powerful
temple in los angeles wilshire boulevard
temple
and
leon went to them and said i'm running
out of money we're gonna have to stop
this because we're paying our spies a
small stipend
uh because most of them the nazis wanted
them because they were following the
same strategy as hitler did in the 20s
hitler recruited his brown shirts out of
world war one veterans who were angry
with the german government for cutting
their benefits well as soon as roosevelt
came into office in march 1933 they
passed the economy act where they cut
the benefits of veterans from 80 to 100
dollars a month to 20 a month and those
veterans were really angry and the
germans thought they could get those
world war one veterans were angry with
their government if they didn't realize
they were even more angry with a foreign
nation coming in and telling them what
to do
anyway they're running out of money
lewis turns to these three guys and says
you have to help
so they in turn particularly mendel
silverberg who was he made lou wasserman
look like a [ __ ] he was the most
powerful person in hollywood
when he told the 40 moguls
the studio heads the major producers a
few directors
show up
at uh
hillcrest country club
on march
15th i think it was 1934
for secret meaning
and they all show up and they have no
idea why they're there but they know
when mendel superberg says go you go
they walk into a private room
all 40 of them and in front of them
table are two issues
of the silver shirt magazines
both filled with the most vile
anti-semitic articles particularly going
after the moguls drawings with the big
hook nose drawings of the moguls
salivating over young christian looking
women
and they're looking at this and you can
only imagine their eyes going up but
what really shocks them he starts off by
saying to them this is only the tip of
the iceberg do you know that nazis and
fascists have invaded your studios and
you are unaware of it and they were like
what
well his spies had reported
that uh below the line personnel which
are 80 to 90 percent of the employees in
the studios these are the crafts workers
the electricians the grips
uh lighting people carpenters etc
that the foreman in every one of the
studios
many of them were members of the silver
shirts of the bund and they were firing
all the jewish employees and it had
gotten to a point where paramount was
now 100 aryan mgm was almost 100 aryan
columbia studios all the others and he's
saying this is going on in your studios
and none of you are aware of this and
let me tell you something else
these same people are plotting to kill
you
well by the end of the evening he walked
out in the equivalent of today's dollars
within like 400 grand
and the moguls for the rest of their
operations spy operation the moguls
underwrote the entire operation and they
had no doubts if they ever have doubts
after at one point leon lewis had
his spies penetrated so deeply that one
of his spies he recruited a former
secretary of the bund who is now angry
at the bund who planted a tape recorder
in hermann schmin's office
and at one point he brought together a
dozen of the moguls and played them a
tape recording of the plot to murder
them this was the hanging plot and as
joseph roose reported in his memoir
unpublished memoir
what took them aback more than anything
else was that the nazis were talking
about murdering them as though they were
talking about going to a sunday picnic
no emotion you're going to do this
you're going to bring this you're going
to do that you're going to do that and
then they'll all be dead
so the moguls in fact
uh and
as i would say it may be the only time
in several thousand years that jews kept
an important secret it never got out
and i've written a lot about hollywood
in the 30s and 40s i've never come
across a mention of the spy ring
or of the jews funding it that's how
tight-lipped they were when it really
mattered
more questions
or is it that you're shy to walk up here
we can
the cake how big was the how big was the
kkk well
they had um the kkk was slowing down in
1922 they did a major raid and where
they discovered there was something like
a
was it 120 people in the sheriff's
department that belonged to the clan
but the clan was still very active
particularly in long beach
and in fact john was alluding before to
the identity of the spies one of the two
key spies
was charles slocum who had been a major
leader of the ku klux klan in long beach
until he had a change of heart
uh he still was an anti-communist but he
could no longer abide the hating of jews
of catholics of other groups because he
felt they were still americans i might
not love these people but they're
americans and he was disgusted what the
clan was doing and this was a truly
heroic man because he never told anybody
through the 1940s
until the end of the war he told no one
that he had been part of this undercover
operation and so his friends apparently
were perplexed they didn't understand
how could this good wholesome american
guy
be
not only a member of the clan but he
rose up he never quit the clan he
pretended to keep and in fact he was the
recruiting officer for the southern
california clan he was also he rose up
to leadership positions in a number of
these smaller fascist groups and he
worked very closely with the silver
shirts and with the uh
head of the silver shirts for los
angeles uh kenneth alexander they were
part of the second plot to kill the 24
hollywood figures and so here is a true
hero a man who was hated by his friends
for most of his life
until he finally revealed after the war
what he had really been doing but even
then it never got publicized these
people
leon lewis
joe roos
slocum went to their death never telling
their stories to anyone publicly
it was a need to know basis and leon
lewis and joe russ never told anyone
because they were afraid i mean this is
how this is how scared they were
joe roos
lived until his
early 90s and worked at us worked for
usc in a public relations firm and he
gave a testimony to the showa foundation
would have been i'm going to guess in
the 80s or so and i watched that
testimony and at one point the
interviewer says to him so
mr roose what happened to your spy neil
ness and joe roos literally jumped out
of his seat freaked out and he said how
do you know that name how do you know
that name where did you hear that and he
was so upset
and the woman said well he testified
before huak in 1939.
ruse had forgotten that but i
interviewed joe ruse's son who told me
that his father never told him anything
about what he and leon lewis were doing
he said the only thing his father ever
told him is that he said you know do you
remember one day when you were boy i
came home and i told you i tripped in
front of the house and my face was all
bruised and he said yeah you broke your
glasses and he said well actually i got
jumped by two nazis and they were
beating me and they probably would have
beaten me to death but a car came by and
slowed down and you know said what's
going on here and they ran away
leon lewis never told his family joe
roose never told his family
and chuck slocum i don't think told his
family until after the war
yes
um
[Music]
the question was
in taking over the armories in san
francisco l.a and san diego was this a
harebrained scheme or was it being
ordered by germany
germany wasn't ordering any of these
plots
because as i discovered germany
in 19 germany
hitler wanted to keep america neutral
and he knew that if there were these
crazy plots and americans were killed
and it could be traced back to nazis
american public opinion would turn
so he didn't start sending my guess well
i know this for sure he didn't start
sending
gestapo agents who were checking out uh
airplane facilities for sabotage
until roughly 1940.
um so
these were all plots started by local
not well m german emigres
who were the main german nazis and by
american fascists who absolutely
believed that america was so
anti-semitic
that so many americans hated jews that
if somebody had the courage to start
killing jews in a major city and if you
did it in three cities simultaneously
this would encourage and give the
backbone to all those other anti-semites
out there who were too afraid and that
they believed they wrote this it's in
the spy reports they believed it would
set off pogroms throughout the entire
united states and that at the very least
if jews weren't all killed they would be
forced to flee america now that's a
little fantastic
but
they were prepared to do it
in germany
worked after kristallnacht
[Music]
question
the question is do i draw any parallels
between my book then and what's going on
now now because i'm a historian but i
have drawn parallels i've written a few
op-eds in the in the last few weeks i
have one in the uh la times from a few
weeks ago and one last week in the
washington post that's where it seems to
me appropriate to draw the parallel and
the main parallel i would draw is that
we are facing
the same question
that
our forebearers from the 30s and 40s in
la faced which is
what do you do when hate groups move
from the margins to the mainstream
and when government authorities seem
either complacent or complicit
what do you do
the first thing is you say
there aren't good people on both sides
i'm sorry there are no good nazis there
are no good white supremacists
there are no good silver shirts there
are no good hate mongers
all these people are filled with hate
i i don't have the
an answer
but the answer is what leon lewis showed
us
is the need to be vigilant
and what's amazing to me is leon lewis
used the most powerful weapon
that we command which is our brain
he foiled all these plots without ever
firing a gun
none of his
spies
ever fired a weapon some of them carried
guns
because they had been threatened by
nazis because the nazis referred to leon
lewis as the most dangerous jew in los
angeles and they knew both the nazis the
silver shirts and all these for cocked
the groups
they knew
that leon lewis had penetrated their
organization and in fact i just did
something with uh
take two this morning a martinez's show
and we shot it right outside leon
lewis's office at 727 west 7th street
and i pointed out to him that
there would be days where either the
bund or one of the silver shirts would
send over somebody to stand across the
street
watching the entrance to leon lewis's
office
because they wanted to see if anyone
they knew
went in there because if they could
identify somebody they knew they would
know who the spy was but they were never
able to do it leon lewis consistently
outsmarted them
but the message i think if he was here
today is
you have to say no to hate
when you hear hate speech you know not
all of us are going to go undercover not
all of us are going to
do these heroic things but heroism
isn't of a massive scale heroism can
just be
you hear somebody saying hateful things
and you turn to them and you say that's
not okay
we don't talk that way
you hear of a demonstration
by hate group go to the demonstration
but don't go prepared for violence this
is where i don't support antifa go and
show
your opposition but if you go saying
we're prepared to engage in violence
then i think you just demean your own
cause
and then you people say see you're no
better than them it is about vigilance
and paying attention and even things
like taking a knee at a football game
which people are mocking it's not about
the flag we know that that's distraction
by donald trump it's about the lack of
democracy in america
or for those of you watching the world
series having a baseball player for
those of you not following it i should
say on the houston team who after he hit
a home run after kenta maeda went back
into the dugout and made a gesture
raising his eyes
like this which the fans in houston
began to do and the baseball
commissioner rather than having the guts
to suspend him right now suspended him
for next year for five games
that's not okay
when you hear hate when you hear that
kind of racism or prejudice
you speak up to me that's the lesson you
speak up
question
oh can you would you come up here to the
mic
yeah
come on up
at the risk of maybe um ruling the end
of the book what what happened to some
of the um
local fascist leaders nazis
either i mean i i assume they were
arrested but then
after the war they disappeared do they
try to yeah yeah that's a good question
the the two leaders
uh
uh hermann schwinn
the head nazi in la number two nazi in
america
and his number one guy hans dibel
were arrested on december 8th 1941
and imprisoned
uh neither of them saw the light of day
until
uh hans daibo i couldn't get his um
i don't know exactly when he was
tossed out of the country but was around
1946
and he was sent back to germany herman
schwenn was kept in jail until 1947
when he agreed to join his buddies in
argentina
and his american wife american-born wife
had been waiting for him patiently went
to argentina but after a year
she had enough of life in argentina and
came back without him to florida
and he followed a little while later
decided he'd rather live with his wife
than fellow nazis but the irony is
herman schwenn
died in 1973
in dade county florida surrounded by my
parents
and all the survivors in the most
heavily survivor county i believe in the
united states i think one of the great
ironies of life
thank you for your intelligence
thank you all for coming tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
1939